à 64 ans l'ancien secrétaire d'état
adjoint de barack obama s'apprête à
diriger l'agencé de renseignement
américaine qualifiée de diplomates
exemplaires par joe biden il a travaillé
avec cinq présidents différents dont
bill clinton et ronald reagan en 1982 il
intègre le service extérieur des états
unis avant d'occuper des postes dans les
ambassades américaines d'après le site
de la fondation carnegie pour la paix
internationale dont il est le président
william burns maîtrise plusieurs langues
étrangères dont l'arabe le français et
le russe entre 2005 et 2008
il est ministre conseiller aux affaires
politiques au sein de l'ambassade des
états unis à moscou sa position
vis-à-vis de la russie reste énigmatique
en 2019 fils qualifié dans une interview
vladimir poutine d'apôtres de la
vengeance sous la présidence de barack
obama
william burns occupe dans un premier
temps le poste de sous secrétaire d'état
aux affaires politiques avant de devenir
secrétaire d'état adjoint à partir de
retraité de la vie diplomatique depuis
2014 william burns est actuellement le
président d'une fondation ouvrant pour
la paix internationale
le peuple américain pourra dormir sur
ses deux oreilles avec lui en tant que
prochain directeur de la cia en août
dernier
william burns n'a pas hésité à critiquer
le président républicain en pointant du
doigt les dommages causés par son
gouvernement sur la politique étrangère
américaine
si le sénat confirme sa nomination
william burns deviendra le premier
diplomate de métier a occupé cette
fonction aux états unis